الموضوع الجاي اللي رح نحكي عنه يمكن يكون
حلم لكل موظفين العالم من قبل الموضوع ما
هو بتحمسني يمكن كلش طيب المهم في شركه
يمكن كثار يطمحوا يشتغلوا فيها الشركه
هنديه واسمها
وهي شركه تكنولوجيا صغيره نسبيا مقرها
مدينه والشركه بتتبنى قانون بيلزم موظفيها
بمغادره العمل بعد انتهاء الدوام لا لا
بيجبرهم على هذا الشيء القصه ان عرفت لما
واحد من الموظفين نشر على صوره للرساله
اللي بتطلع على شاشه جهازه واجهزه زملائه
وقبل نهايه الدوام بعشر دقائق الرساله
بتقول انه الدوام قرب يخلص والسيستم راح
يعمل شد داون خلال عشر دقايق قوموا امشوا
طبعا الشركه اثارت الانتباه والاهتمام
والكل يجري عليها بيعرف يشهد الشركه ومن
اصحابها وكيف بيفكروا المديره هناك قالوا
انهم يعو جيدا اهميه التوازن بين العمل
والحياه الخاصه وانه بيهمهم جدا موظفينهم
يقدروا وقت مع عائلاتهم
واحبائهم يعني ولا مش تركات والله الصراحه
يعني